[MUSIC]
Hey, welcome to Dean's office hours.
I am so excited.
This is almost like the closing
ceremonies for application week.
I hope you have had as great
a time this week as I have.
We are joined today by the assistant dean
of MBA admissions and financial aid,
Kristin Moss.
So just to give a little rundown of
what we're going to be doing today,
easy outline, we're going to click
welcome, from there, introductions.
So, we've already knocked
that welcome out.
We're going to have a discussion,
a fireside chat.
I love these conversations.
I get the honor of getting
to work with Kirsten, but
every time we host one of these,
I learn something new.
And I leave with that little,
aha, moment that I'm like, yeah,
maybe we could try that.
Let's do something a little different.
And then we'll definitely use the Q&A box.
So, as I said before,
please ask your questions there.
We also have a team of folks online,
who will be helping behind the scenes.
We'll have about 15 minutes together.
And just so everybody knows,
these videos will be posted.
There was going to be a little
bit of a short turnaround.
Some of our events from the beginning
of the week are already posted.
So, if you want to come
back to these ever,
to refresh on some different ways to maybe
kickstart your process or find moments
of inspiration to get you to that end
of that application to click submit.
We are here for it and we will
always be there at your fingertips.
So, I'm going to go ahead and
stop screen share.
Kirsten, I know I might have spoiled
your intro a little bit, but
could you please introduce yourself and
in similar spirit to the question,
we asked attendees,
how about if you could fill in the blank.
One of your professional goals is,
and then.
>> Great, thank you Will, and
thank you for the delightful introduction.
Just as it's inspiring to read about
all the students, the potential,
the applicants who are out there and
what you're passionate about.
It's fun to be here and share my own.
So Will, an answer to your question,
I feel so fortunate that I love my job.
So my post professional goal or
my goal right now is to keep this job.
So keep your fingers crossed,
that I'll have it for a long time.
But more specifically one of the goals
that I know both of us share and it's so
important.
In the last few years,
Will I have been talking about,
how do we really make our process
as transparent as possible,
so that whoever's applying can
put their best foot forward?
And little by little,
we've been trying to crack this nut.
So I'm really excited today to have this
final session as we continue to just make
it as easy as possible for
anyone listening today,
to get to the next step
in your own journey.
And hopefully you'll consider Stanford,
what can we do to make sure that
you understand how to get here?
>> Yeah, it's funny how, from our first
discussions and then as we've seen
things evolve, how we've absorbed in
our kind of living that change lives,
change organizations,
change the world's- So true.
>> Philosophy, it was just something that
you absorb even by working at the GSB.
So, watching it happen with our
students is that much more special.
>> Yeah, and this is really the first time
that we've ever had an application week
like this before.
So huge shout out back to Will,
for his brainstorm and
the entire team who's put this together.
We're so excited to deliberate.
>> Yeah, we're talking about both program,
but even internally,
we're always thinking about how we
can Improve the things that we do and
what we offer including the application.
I know you've led our team
in that design process.
And I want to know, can you provide
any insights into your goals,
especially as a leader with your
vision for where we go next.?
What are your goals for
the application and evaluation process?
>> It's a great question and
a way Will Beth brings us, it's so
easy in the application
because it's complex or
how we evaluate to get
down in the details.
Who's your reference?
Who's the best person to do that?
Or how do i do my resume?
But one of the things that I've tried to
think a lot about at the highest level is,
where are we aiming for?
When we built this evaluation system and
the application,
what was really the end goal
of what we're trying to do?
And if we get very simplistic for
anybody listening,
hopefully this will help you as
you're writing your own applications.
There's really three things that I think
are most important to us at Stanford.
And one is,
we're an educational institution.
So, the number one thing is,
we're trying to find students who
are going to be engaged in that classroom.
And maybe all of you can reflect for
a moment, go back to university or
even high school.
Was there a class that you just
loved that you felt alive and
where everyone's hand was up?
And what was the teacher like and
how did you show up?
That's what the admissions team is trying
to find, is students who will come into
our classrooms and not only share their
own perspectives, but be this curious and
excited to learn, and
our faculty it will feed on itself.
So one of the priorities I'm always
holding as we design our application and
process is, how do we make sure
we're getting that data, so
we can find students who really
appreciate learning-for-learnings sake?
So that's one.
And then the second thing,
Will already mentioned, our tagline of
change lives, change organizations,
change the world.
In some ways that can sound, I don't know,
high and mighty, like too hard to achieve.
The reality is, every time we pick
up an application, we're looking for
people who will have positive impact
when they go out there and graduate.
And it's actually hard.
We struggle,
we refine this application all the time
because it's not as if we're in a company.
Let's say you're in consulting right now,
and you interview,
there's some skills that someone
who's a consultant needs to have.
For us, we want leaders to go out across
the globe, in every industry and whether
it's for profit or non-profit, education,
could be journalism, media, finance.
So, how do we find those characteristics
that really help people have
leadership impact no matter
what they aspire to do?
Or I love whoever said that they want to
build a company that will spread love
in the world.
How do I find just that person,
who's got the capability to
spread love in the world?
So I'd say that's the second
thing that we're looking for,
is this evidence that that you will go out
and impact the world in a positive way.
And then third and
really important for Stanford, so
I'm reminded of this often,
our community is small.
What you'll hear our alumni and
students and faculty say is that,
it's a place where in Silicon Valley,
where our goal is to lift everyone up.
It's to fail and fail often, but
to really, be thinking beyond oneself.
And so, I'm looking when I read
applications to find evidence of,
and to ask you data about, how I'm
hoping to see that you will come and
strengthen our community.
That you will be someone who, again,
will not only develop themselves,
but help in the development of others,
and you can do that in so many ways.
But that's what's special about Stanford,
is we're all working together.
And I think it's special about innovation
and entrepreneurship in the Valley,
that ecosphere we come from is really,
that we solve things with each other.
You can't do it alone.
So I'd say, Will,
those at the very top, are my goals.
And then it's not surprising that when
we publish on the web what we look for,
it maps to that.
You'll see, and I'm sure if you've
attended another session, we talked about
intellectual vitality, that's engagement,
when you'd be in the classroom.
We talked about demonstrated leadership
potential, which is really the past impact
you've had, so what have you done out
there in the world that we can look to?
And then personal qualities and
contributions?
So, how have you gone through the world?
What are your values, the choices
you've made, how you've shown up to.
And from that,
we're looking at what that would mean for
you to come to our community and
help us be stronger.
Yeah there's been a phrase
that I used once and
somehow it stuck background agnostic,
context dependent.
>> I love it.
>> Out there.-
>> Yeah.
>> A little bit more.
But I know in the past I've had questions
from people like I'm from a non
traditional background or I'm from,
like, how do I demonstrate, right?
And so as you think about intellectual
vitality, like that can come in so
many different facets of your life and for
us, it doesn't matter where it shows up.
We celebrate it where it does and
then context right like,
how it's going to show up maybe in
the individual who's a consultant.
It might look very different from someone
who's helping lead a family business.
So just know that for folks out there.
It is about you and
like the world around you.
>> And would it be helpful to even go one
level deeper, deeper on that level and
explains so dive down.
I'd love that you brought up that one
first is intellectual vitality because
with the other ones that might
be easier for us to say, well,
that's what we're looking for.
So then when we built the application,
where do you as a applicant
demonstrate those things?
But I always find the intellectual
vitality almost the hardest because you
can find it anywhere.
And I think one of the misses we're
just looking at GPA and test scores.
In reality, we're looking for evidence
that you've had interesting ideas,
fundamentally what leaders
do if we think about that
leaders are influencing others to
collaborate towards a common goal.
And part of that maybe having a good
idea about how to solve a problem so
it could be just as much in the day
to day work that you're having now.
Where you thought of something someone
else hadn't or someone shared an idea and
you jumped on it to help that team move
in just a little different direction.
I mean, I would say intellectual vitality.
We'll get to the gold star on our team
this week because this is a great
example of us.
Just talking as an institution
as a team and saying, hey,
we want to be more transparent.
How can we really be helpful and
beginning to see a new way
that we might do something?
So we'd love to see in your application,
it might come from your references,
it might come in your short answers.
It might come from the kinds of things
you studied on your transcript.
Those are all places where you can
demonstrate that you're curious and
engaged and
thinking about new ways to do things.
>> Yeah, and as we're talking about things
popping up across kind of the whole
application, just the concept
of the holistic review process.
I've talked a lot about it this week.
I think people have heard my explanation
for it, but it would be really nice to
hear how you articulate and
understand the holistic review process.
I know I've talked about
the application and
each section is like a part of the picture
and each helps us understand, like,
who you might be in our classroom and
community?
And things are just like we're
making assessments on the whole and
not just on any one piece.
How would you explain it to someone if
they asked you what is the holistic review
process?
>> I think you just heat it up well,
well and that
you can't make a decision on any applicant
from just a part of the application.
But I also it's easy to be up here and
I know many schools, a holistic and skull.
What does that mean?
You know, tell me more about that.
So I think if we go back to what I just
said about the goals that we're looking
for someone who's engaged in a class,
who's done positive things in their
community and also will help to make
a positive community wherever they are.
Like those should be your guiding north,
but
they will we have to look across your
your essays which are going to really
it'll shed light on who you are and the
choices you made and what you care about.
As well as our short answers,
which tells us like what you have done and
then looking at some of the other,
as I said for intellectual Vitality,
we can find it in different places.
We are looking like a heat-seeking missile
through all of this as we read and
there's no, like I was laughing, Will,
as I was thinking about our talk today.
If someone asked me like,
how do you read an application,
I feel like every time I read
an application, it's different.
Because as I'm going through maybe I'll
start with the with your biographical
information.
I'll immediately have a question that
comes up and I'll maybe it is about
intellectual vitality, and
I'll jump to your transcript over.
So I'd be happy to share a little
bit more about how that works.
But the point is, it's holistic, you need
all of these parts in order to come up
with a good assessment
at the end of the day.
>> There have been a lot
of questions about process,
[LAUGH] so I wanted to direct make sure
that we spent some time today too.
So this is kind of like the perfect segue.
>> Awesome.
>> People have been curious
about the process, so
any light that you could shed into it?
And then, understanding like, okay, to
what extent is understanding our process?
Valuable versus like, how can we focus our
energies such that we can show up our best
selves in the application?
>> So that's a great question and maybe I
can give some examples even of how I read
applications to bring it more to life.
But at the top level,
what we're with the admissions team,
all the admissions officers and I are
trying to do that we're trying to give you
real estate so
that you can tell your whole story.
And we've even given you these optional
questions to make sure you have enough
space to do it.
So rest considering that in its entirety
and a little bit of a different way,
but there's more important written
information put in one place or
another, because it will vary so
much by person.
So I would not get hung up at all about
how is person going to read my particular
application.
I would be thinking much more
about how can I make sure that she
knows Knows that I'm curious,
she knows about my stories.
I'm most proud of the impact,
what I've done and also,
she knows who I am as a person,
he or she, I should say.
Okay, when I read applications,
I'll try to think of some examples.
With real examples, and
I've read thousands.
So hopefully this will be easy, Will.
So usually we'll start at the very
beginning of the application you're
going to fill out just to
get a sense of who you are.
In terms of where you're born and
where you're going to school and
some that biographical information,
but oftentimes even from there,
I'm taking leaps into other
parts of the application.
So for instance, maybe I'm getting
that you were you went to school and
what you studied and you studied classics,
and then I see you're at Citibank.
And that'll be like, wow,
how did that happen?
And before I want to learn
more about Citibank,
I'll probably jump to your transcript,
and say, what did you study?
Did you have any finance or quant courses?
Because holistic to use your phrase,
the way that you perform, or what you
worked on at Citi may be very different
from someone in the beginning at least of
your career Then someone who spent four
years as a business or economics major.
Sso that might be a good example of
how we're constantly asking ourselves
questions or maybe if I see in your in
that information about college that you
you paid for a significant part of
your college or that your first gen.
I might immediately jump to
your essay then think, wow,
that must have been really hard but
there are other things in your context and
how you've grown up that might shed light
or a lens on the choices you've made or
the transcript or
the classes that you've taken all of that.
So it'll be really individual for
each person.
But I would think about telling
us from your perspective,
how can you be most strategic to answer
those goals those three goals I gave you.
Was that helpful, Will?
Hope I helped you out here?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and
I think that also starts
to come into play.
There's a question from Bruce.
>> Yeah.
>> About the admissions, the values.
That the admissions committee holds and
what guides our decision making process.
And I think for us,
it is that understanding and
not just the projection of ideas and
notions but also evidence.
So every time we're reading we're
looking for in the application.
Here's where intellectual
vitality like some form
of intellectual vitality
might come to life.
And maybe it is in your writing,
maybe it's in the letter of reference.
So I think That evidence piece of it,
kind of on the tactical practical.
The better folks are able to articulate,
not just the what, but the how.
I think that's one of those on
the practical side of things things
that help guide us and, okay,
let's make a coherent, yes,
look to admit kind of decision evidence.
>> We're looking for
those patterns of evidence.
And I want to caution as you're thinking
about in the next five weeks, for
those of you who are thinking first round,
putting together your application.
I love what Will said about being agnostic
about where you've done it in the context.
What I would start with is,
when we think about especially that
demonstrated leadership potential piece,
what are the things that you've done
in your life that you're most proud of?
So if we get to sit together tomorrow,
we're having a cup of coffee, and
I get to ask you the question.
Bruce, tell me about a time that you've
had an impact that was meaningful to you,
really thinking,
what have I done that I've worked on,
not what's important to Kirsten.
because I speak over and over with
prospects who think that they needed to be
the president of the student body, or
they needed to go to a certain school, or
a certain kind of company.
And the reality is going
back to that last example,
if you're the first person in your
family who was able to go to college, or
you ended up having to pay for a third of
your college, to me, that's leadership.
That's persistence.
That's grit.
That's taking risk.
That's showing initiative.
So if you start with yourself because you
understand your context better than any of
us could,
don't project what we want to hear.
What have you been working really hard on?
And I believe each of us has
some stories that are powerful.
And just making sure, at least for
Stanford, we can't speak for other
schools, but at Stanford, that's where
we're seeing leadership come to life.
>> And so, as we're talking about the
application and how we can put our best
foot forward, this whole week has been
about tips, advice, best practices.
So is it okay if we go in that direction,
Kirsten?
Good, knowing that between the two of us,
thousands of applications,
and even talking to our teammates, right,
I want to say there's at least
a century of admissions experience.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> And so
hopefully some of our observations
come with some backing there.
But this week, we split even our workshops
into how do you start your story?
How do you communicate it
in the written format?
And then when it comes to speaking,
because speaking is also going to be,
not just part of the application process,
but
a consistent part of
the journey throughout.
So maybe starting at that
starting your story, so for
folks who might be thinking
about business school or
really trying to put together the threads
and the details of maybe why?
Do you have any tips or advice for folks
and things that they might consider as
they're pulling together the rationale for
business school or for Stanford?
>> So that why Stanford question,
is that what you're speaking about?
>> Yeah,
just broadly as people are preparing so.
>> Yeah, really, when I think about the
essays and short answers you're writing,
for me they fall into those two camps,
which is what have you done?
And we just talked about that, that would
be really starting with what are you proud
of the impact that you've had?
And I'm going to pause there again too,
because this impact could be
very individual to you as well.
Maybe you're a violinist and
you worked really hard and
you performed in ensembles or
in symphonies.
That may be the way that you're
going to demonstrate leadership to us.
Or maybe it's in your church, or your
mosque, or with your family, helping them,
there's so
many ways that you can show that.
But think about what you've done,
that's where I would start first, and
reflect and jot down.
And I use three stories because I
want you to kind of have a chance to
play with that and brainstorm,
think outside of the box.
because it may be something that you're
proud of that you wouldn't necessarily
have led with, if that makes sense,
so that's part A.
The second part that we talked about
was how you've walked through life,
who you are as a person,
what are your values and motivations?
And our essay about what matters most and
why gets to the absolute heart.
And it's probably one of the hardest
essays you're likely to answer,
[LAUGH] that's the hard news.
For me, you've probably
gotten a lot of advice, but
for me personally,
if I had to put in my two cents on that.
If you could look back over the last,
since college, for many of you,
that's eight years.
You've made choices,
you've decided what to major in, and
you've decided what extracurricular
activities you've been involved in.
You've decided what types of
organizations to work for
post potentially,
if you have had work experience.
And at the time, you may not have thought
very much about why you're making
these choices, but
now you have an opportunity to go back and
connect the dots and
see what those things are.
I know I was working or
speaking with a candidate recently and
they're telling me about what
they had done in college.
And they had been an RA in their
college dorm, they had been a TA for
a teacher in some courses,
they'd done that twice.
They had signed up to be
a wellness counselor.
And immediately we're seeing this theme
that whether it was in academics, or
in living situations, or
even on the wellness side of just
helping people develop and grow.
And that's like, well,
there you go, that's a big aha.
So maybe you can look
over your choices and
think about what's been important to you,
and why you've made them.
And you will start to understand
what those deeper values are.
So that would be the advice
I'd give on the essay as well.
>> Yeah,
[LAUGH] there's a kind of preparation tip,
process that I shared with people,
remember, reflect, process, connect.
>> Love it, yeah.
>> Just remember the things you did,
reflect on the circumstances around it.
Process how did that kind of matter and
why was it significant?
And then connect the dots between
the different parts of your life and
how might it inform your journey.
So I was trying to put it in a catchy
phrase that people could remember if
they're like, okay, if I need to sit down,
what's an easy way to think and
prepare with some of
the things that I've done?
So, kind of plugging
that pneumonic in there.
>> Yeah, I love it, I totally love it,
I love your pneumonic.
So I'm going to steal that next
time I'm in another group.
>> Do it.
>> Maybe what's also important
is to go back to the why.
Why does Stanford ask this question?
We've been asking it at least for two
decades, and I'm not going to change it.
So if you're going to apply in a year or
two,
you'll still have the luxury
of doing this question.
There has been tremendous research on
looking at leaders later in their journey,
what prompted their impact or prompted the
results that they were able to achieve?
And one of the distinctions that we see is
leaders who know what their values are and
can speak to their motivation, tend to
use that as the energy to take risks, and
to take initiative.
So we're looking for you to reflect
on what could those motivations be,
and that will help guide
yourself in the future.
Now Will and I are not going to
evaluate what values you have,
so this is a projective question.
For us, it's more about your
self-awareness and reflection, and
knowing who you are and
could be as a leader.
So that when you come to Stanford,
you're ready to take advantage of
all the opportunities we have here.
And go ahead, Will say.
>> Yeah, no, it's almost like you're
kickstarting that leadership development
and leadership curriculum.
Because there's so much introspection
that's required to answer,
why should someone follow you?
Or why should someone want to
follow you to be even more precise?
I really appreciate the question.
I've mentioned it before, I often use
it as a kind of way to make decisions
when I met pivot points in life,
so even beyond the application,
I think it's Embracing
the process of applying,
there are some greater learnings
that can be had oftentimes, and
the way I grew up, it's like you apply for
a thing and then that's it.
Whereas in this process,
there's also, it's an invitation for
greater learnings that I never realized
could have been part of something like
applying to school before.
Yeah, and I love that.
And it's also our second essay,
why Stanford?
What are your aspirations and
how will you get there?
It's the same.
We're asking you on the one hand to look
back at what your motivations were, and
then to use those to tell us what you
might be interested in working on or
solving in your future.
I think it's worth saying in this
is different than other schools.
So I really want to make sure
we're just speaking for Stanford.
We don't have Career Services
sitting on our admissions committee.
We really believe if you get into Stanford
that you are capable of what achieving
whatever dreams and aspirations you have,
that won't happen necessarily immediately.
Maybe there are pivots or
expertise you have to gain but
we know that you'll get there.
So you should feel free to write about
whatever you want in those aspirations.
And we also know that
those are going to change,
the vast majority of our students think
they'll do something when they come in and
we'll do something very different when
they graduate and that's okay, too.
So again, this is a question to say, have
you thought enough about what you care
about, that you can have a true north,
even though that might shift west or
east and you'll go through this journey.
But we're really curious
about at this moment in time,
what's important to you and
what would you like to work on?
Yeah, because even if it's not the first
thing after there's probably going to be
at least a few pivots in your life.
This is just one stop in a career and
life basically that extends beyond.
Yes, you will take the memories,
and community and
the learnings from the GSD with you, but
It's really to empower you to be able to
thrive regardless of your circumstance and
situation, I think.
Yeah.
Right, and then so we often talk
a lot about the writing, the essays.
An area that I know we both find
fascinating that we don't get to talk
too much about is the interview.
Yeah.
And I know you have a really
rich history and assessment.
Can you talk us through like the Stanford
behavioral based interview, any
advice that you might give for folks and
how to think about, what it looks like?
Yeah, yes well, for us,
we will interview somewhere between
10 to 15% of our applicants.
So if you get the email inviting
you to interview, congratulations.
That's a wonderful step in the process.
Our interviews are done by
alumni across the globe.
So they'll have your resume and
not your whole application.
So it's your chance to share with them
open a little bit more detail their story.
But let's go back to your question well,
why do we structure the way that our
interviews and the way that we do?
Their behavioral based
structural interviews and
what they're meant to do is to really take
this application which is enough flat
piece of paper to bring it to life.
It's your opportunity to really
bring it to living color.
And we basically will ask you the same
questions that you're answering in your
short answers.
Tell us about a time you've had had
an impact that was meaningful or tell us
about a time you've had a challenge, tell
us about a time you've worked on a team.
And notice that tell us about a time
language, that's very typical of
behavioral based interviews for
those of you who have not done them.
What we're trying to do here
is we believe that your past
behavior will predict future behavior.
So you had an opportunity your application
in the essays are short answers to tell us
about some of those stories that you
think are important and you're proud of.
But when we're reading an application,
we don't have a chance to probe and
really bring those to life.
So what could be a good example to really,
I'm going to play, this is an interview
will really make this concrete and the why
behind what we're trying to do here.
Let's say that many of our
applicants come from finance.
Maybe you were asked to help
build a training program or
launch a new initiative on training for
new analysts that are coming in and
you, right, you give us a short answer
question about that maybe 200 words.
So that's a really exciting leadership,
I call it impact moment.
But maybe your interviewer as your
when he asks you a question like,
tell me about a time
you've taken initiative.
You leave with this example and
the interviewer might want to know
well how many students attended that?
Or how long was the training program?
Or how did you get permission to
even to do it or the resources?
Or how did you develop the curriculum?
So all of these things we may or may not
have been able to ask you about in a flat
application, but in your interview,
you can bring it to life.
And I think, so
these interviews in some ways,
you won't have a lot of
additional preparation.
because you've already been thinking
about those important stories.
But I want to make sure, because I
do some of the interviews as well.
One potential, what I call it or
tip something to avoid is make sure
when you come to your interview,
you know that you're the hero.
And heroes can be humble.
So as you come in and really think about,
what was the situation, you saw there was
a problem and that new analysts weren't
getting the training they needed.
What did you do about it?
So what actions did you
as an individual take?
Why was Is that important?
Why was that meaningful
to the organization?
So what happened from it and be willing
to step in that and be the hero.
And again, heroes can be humble,
but you still need to own.
This was what I did in this initiative.
So that's the best way I think you
could prepare for our interviews.
I was laughing because I thought you were
going to ask me to like demo with you.
I'm glad we did it, we did.
Yeah, probably yesterday Yeah.
One of the tips I shared yesterday and
kind of ingesting the phrasing.
There's no I and T but there isn't admit,
I was joking but the point was,
even in a group setting, there's something
that you might have done as an individual.
And there's something you didn't do as
an individual to help advance something
from point A to point B.
A lot of us it's hard to shift out
of that we mentality and embrace,
and really center yourself.
I know,
I remember one of our interviews Kirsten.
No.
Even having done interview as myself,
you're like, well you keep saying we,
what did you do?
Even though it was an example, I knew,
you were actually involved and
I was like, wait.
So definitely it's a real thing, and we
encourage and we want to know about you.
So just, we invite you to
center yourself in your attic.
That's fantastic advice.
Absolutely right.
And oftentimes, it took a group to get
things done, but just like you said, well,
you were taking actions
that help that group.
So speak to those.
And if we do probe,
it's because we want to learn more and
we're trying to help you
get towards something.
That will be helpful for us as we
understand your application as a whole.
And the other thing is,
we are blessed on our team.
Carrie Oliver has been running
our interviews for a long time,
she's trained a hundreds of alumni across
the globe, they love to participate and
come back every year.
So a part of this too is just to meet
someone who really cares about Stanford
and who wants to get to know you and
you them.
So once you're done with behavioral
based part of the interview,
there'll be a wonderful moment at the end
where you can ask them questions,
learn more about Stanford.
And that's again, just the time to
be yourself, relax, develop rapport,
get to know someone new.
Yeah, Carrie has been such
a gift to the program,
it has really shined,
I think about the recent years.
Kind of shifting away
from the application now.
So we've kind of moved through
the process, how do you think about it,
how do you prepare,
we talked about essays,
that interview which is at next step
as part of the holistic process.
But again, this is just the one step along
the journey and We want to make sure that
you're going to thrive at business school,
so having seen so many journeys through.
Do you have any tips for folks to help
them hit the ground running once they're
at school and
really maximize the opportunity?
Kind of with the notion that also as
you're preparing for business school,
that's what we're looking for
in the application process as well.
So how can someone actually set
themself up for a long term success.
And really think about the big picture
here and not just the application?
>> Yeah, well, it's so easy to get caught
up with all these deadlines coming and
essays and
everything else you just pick this done.
We have designed their process
to try to help you reflect and
be prepared for business school.
One thing I may say is this is,
most of you in the audience have had,
I'm guessing you went to college,
had that experience.
Now you've been working for several years
and there's been more of a path about,
what do I have to do to succeed?
And this is probably one of the first
times in your life where there are no
more boxes to check necessarily.
[LAUGH] The world is open for
you to figure out what do you care about,
what do you want to work on?
What's your own, how you're going to
find energy to show up everyday,
and be excited about what you're doing.
So it's a great,
as you think about this transition.
Your job as you're coming to
business school is not to,
obviously it's to do well in
the classroom and get involved.
But it's also to really uncover for
yourself,
what will be most important to you
when you graduate to begin working on.
And there are so many opportunities
at Stanford and other schools for
you to sample whatever
expertise you want to develop.
And it's across disciplines for us, so it
could be in any of the graduate schools.
Whether you have an interest in
health care, education, or policy,
the world is an oyster.
So I hope during this time and
over the summer as you transition.
One of the things you can do is begin
to think, what would be my priorities?
What do I want to learn more about,
what do I want to dive into even
though I know that will evolve?
So when the world is completely open,
I have some way to prioritize what
could be most important to me.
And so I'd say coming up with a list
of what those, it's in your probably,
what are your aspirations that's
probably helping you to get that list?
So that's one, two rest,
[LAUGH] what we hear from folks coming in
our first term is the classes are hard.
And they take [LAUGH] a lot of time and
there's all the social things happening.
So really knowing,
even though some of you may be in roles
right now where you work extra hard.
I've heard from folks in finance,
they work weekends and all of this, but
I've heard from those same
students when they come in.
That it was just as intensive that those
first few terms here in a different way,
maybe a little more fun at times.
But certainly intensive, and also
another tip is look at your quantitative
preparation and as an applicant as well.
So we will, some of you have had lots
of exposure to that in the past, for
those of you who haven't.
If you haven't taken statistics,
or economics, micro or
macro economics, or calculus.
Those will be core skills that you,
I shouldn't say calculus necessarily but
some kind of higher level math.
There's going to be skills
here that you'll need to rely
on even in that first term.
So before you're applying,
if you notice that you have not
had some of that classwork.
You might want to speak in additional
information about what kind of
prep you will be getting, something
like an MBA math could be helpful.
But you want to make
sure when you get here,
you have some understanding of
the fundamentals of those topics.
And then I think lastly,
my most favorite thing to say is,
we get so excited when I about
getting you to Stanford.
And kind of falling in love with
your [LAUGH] application, and
we can't wait to meet you.
You also if you're selected,
there's so few spots, I guess I'd say.
There's a responsibility to think about
how you're going to also as a leader show
up and help build this community.
And it's never too early,
you can start over the summer,
think about your classes you want to take.
But also what's going on in campus and
what problems, are not problems,
I should say.
But what are some of the ways that you
can become part of the community in
a deep way?
And that often means stepping in and
taking initiative to support others help
others, so I'd love for
you if I could give that advice.
To be thinking in the summer and
actually whatever program you go to,
that this is a chance to start your own
sort of personal leadership journey.
And begin to help and build others up over
the next two years in a really safe place.
That will, and
those kinds of commitments and
investments will last
again over a lifetime.
You'll be part of the Stanford
community for 40 years [LAUGH] or 50.
As long as you're alive, so
whatever connections and
investment you're making now will pay
dividends for all of us in the future.
>> Yeah, and I want to add maybe one more,
we want you to succeed and thrive.
And that also means it's okay to ask for
help, like whether it's academical,
because you might have been
out of school for a while.
And it's a different type of engagement,
and
intensity than maybe in your work life.
So it might be academic help, there's
academic support, there's career help.
There's also counseling and psychological
services help, knowing that this is
going to be a really intensive demanding
experience on multiple fronts.
And sometimes, it helps to have
someone to talk to, who gets it and
can help guide you through the process.
So it's okay to ask for help,
we want you to ask for help, and
there are multiple spaces
that can be support networks.
So make sure that maybe even if it's not
the journey you thought it would be.
We're still making progress and moving
towards whatever goal it is you have.
So I just want to make sure that's
also risen to the top here.
>> Great, great, well.
>> And then kind of full circle,
people are on campus, we have students,
I know sometimes folks say,
nobody gets in, we have a class.
We say sometimes, the only surefire way
to not get admitted is to not apply.
But to that effect, what are some
of the reasons you've heard from
admitted students about why
they almost didn't apply?
What were some of the things
that held them back and
then ultimately they made it through.
>> It is remarkable will,
and I don't know if it's,
because we all are having
posteur syndrome at some level.
[LAUGH] All of us is
just deep in our hearts.
But when I come to edit weekend, it seems
like one of the most common refrain.
So they get to meet all our new students
is, Kirsten, I almost didn't apply.
They start with that, and it's for so
many different reasons, so even for
those who were admitting in the class.
There's this feeling that it felt,
they had to be courageous to
be able to share what we're asking him and
actually hit that Submit button.
But for me, it could be, sometimes people
say, well, I was from consulting or
finance.
And everybody applies from that was it,
I just didn't think I'd stick it out.
Or someone else will say, I'm not from
consulting, I'm not from finance, so
you're not going to want
to read my application.
So even that is funny, or
I didn't study business so
I didn't know whether or not I would
fit in or you would be interested.
Or I went to a community college or
a State College, not an Ivy League.
So I didn't think I would have a shot,
what else are, we have one conversation,
I remember he was a pastor.
He's like, you wouldn't believe that I
really wanted to be a business person.
So whatever your imposter is telling
you that little Gremlin voice,
know that none of these would
be reasons not to apply.
And many of the things I just talked to
would add to kind of the diversity of your
perspective in our class.
Would be something we would
look at as a positive,
not a negative a positive that you
started at a community college.
And were able to perhaps transfer or
be able to graduate in the first place.
So Just don't stop yourself because you're
the only one who can really hit that
Submit button.
>> Yeah, take that strength race, strength
based approach, here's what I contribute,
this is who I am.
>> I love it, yeah.
>> And share that with us because
then doors really do open.
>> And imagine,
imagine me listening to and I say,
that's a common refrain how
many students I'm like.
What if these students had not applied?
It would be I think not only a tragedy for
us in our in our class but
also the future of- Our world in someways,
because we're really relying on you to
go out and create this positive impact.
So you're early in your career, the time
is now to try that, to share yourself and
take that risk.
>> Yeah, all right, so
we do have some time left.
I want to make sure we do
jump into that Q&A box.
So here's the one of the top voted
questions from your non, and
this is a question about, when it comes
down to two individuals or two files,
if there's a close match, how do we think
through the decision making process?
And maybe even just taking it beyond the
hypothetical of, we just have to, what,
again, just to kind of go over some of the
things we talked about at the beginning.
What are some of the things that folks can
kind of make sure that they're thinking
through to put their best foot forward?
>> Yeah, hey Will,
this is an awesome question, and
I've been doing a lot of talking.
So I'm going to switch gears and say,
how about you take a first shot, and I'll
take a second because I wonder if we're
even a little different than how we might.
>> Yeah, this is one of those
times where it helps to know
that there is a committee, right?
And it's not just one individual
who's making the decision.
There's multiple folks who are both taking
a look at the individual as well as
the wholeness of the class.
And the decision making process is going
to actually change year to year based on
the context of that class.
So for me, it's hard to make a clear,
like x, these are the things we look for
because there's so
many different elements involved.
It is the holistic review process, so
that is kind of my non-answer, answer.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, it isn't, again,
and it's a tough question, I know.
Will's right that the decisions are made
within the admissions committee,
so it's not just one voice who's
looking at any application.
I know for me though, sometimes I'm trying
to make, even when I'm looking at my own
pool and trying to make
recommendations on candidates,
there might be two who feel very close.
That's part of our job, I tend to go back
in and I'll use what Will said before, for
this evidence,
we know what our criteria are.
And where I really go back into
the application again, and
remind myself of where I've
seen intellectual vitality,
remind myself of the kinds
of impact someone has had.
Or who they are as a person and
that helps ground me, and
oftentimes both individuals could
be really fabulous candidates.
So I want everyone to know to,
I advise to go wide on
your MBA applications because luck
isn't maybe the best word to use.
But we have many more candidates
than we could put in one class.
So hopefully that makes you feel
better that it's never like,
I'll just take this one.
It's always like okay, I need to go in and
really make sure that this
is the right decision.
And the same token though,
at any given moment,
an application could be looked at in
different ways by different people.
So you guys get the chance to
try to apply to multiple places.
>> And there's a question here that
I'll actually take Kristen if it's okay.
>> Yeah.
>> This is from Daniel, about, yet
we haven't seen the whole team.
But the idea of representation is
something that they think about to win,
but also things that folks from
underrepresented backgrounds,
that it's really important
to have representation, so
they feel comfortable in
the application process.
I see you all are currently hiring
an assistant director for outreach and
diversity.
How have you all committed to ensuring
underserved communities have access to
a degree program like this?
This and so-
>> And you're [CROSSTALK] hiring actually,
so send your resume to Will, that's great.
>> That's actually my own role.
>> Yeah.
>> And
I think that's one of the beautiful things
about our office is that even though
I might be stepping out of that position,
I'm now leading this team.
That doesn't mean that I
stopped doing that job.
So now I'm able to help coach, mentor and
support whoever takes on that role,
and now there's multiple people.
Programs like application week and really
shifting the way that we think about
our programming, so that rather than
just telling you about the school, but
given tools and frameworks for better
understanding of the application process.
I like to think of that as
closing that equity gap, and
that piece of equity being like
the knowledge of how to apply.
Sometimes it can feel like a black box and
if you don't know anybody who hasn't gone
through it before, who has gone through
it before, who do you turn to for help?
And so that's one of the things I find so
empowering and motivating about working
in this office and being able to work with
Kirsten is that, we think a lot about how
can we make sure this process is as open,
accessible and equitable as possible.
And so, Danielle, please know and
to everybody out there,
we take this very seriously and we are
looking to support everyone out there, so
that you can all have a fair shot and
opportunity to attend a school like
Stanford or any other institution
that you hope to go to.
So just wanted to put that plug in there.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah and Will, I'll jump in,
thank you for asking that really
important question, Danielle.
I also look to the senior leadership
of all of Stanford as well as the GSB.
And it is one of the highest priorities
of the school right now to make sure
that our classes represent the diversity
that's out there in our communities.
And for me to have the honor
of holding this position,
we do take that very seriously.
And hopefully you've seen on our web,
we've been much more transparent about
the backgrounds and the identities of
the students that are coming in, and
trying with opportunities like this and
Will's broad shoulders and his teams.
And many others on our team, trying to
increase the number of people in our
pipelines that people who apply, so
that we can continue to make progress.
And we have made some pretty dramatic
progress even in the last three years, and
the diversity of your class.
And are going to continue to fight,
whether it's gender, ethnicity, and
all different kinds of diversity.
So the fact that you're here is
a really phenomenal sign, and
we're glad you're part
of the audience today.
And hopefully these and
other efforts will continue to
make us successful on that front.
because that's my job, I want the
boardrooms of tomorrow to look like what
our communities are, not to look like
what they've looked in the past.
>> Right, Kristen, the time flew by,
we have a couple of minutes.
>> Yeah.
>> We can close out with advice,
words of wisdom or words of encouragement
that you have for the group,
I think that would be an amazing
way to close out application week.
>> All right, I will do this though,
will only if you will close after my close
because you are one of
the heroes of this week.
I have such appreciation, so
it'd be wonderful you do the final wrap,
is that fair?
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] All right.
All right, so, I do this job,
fundamentally because I believe that each
of us has potential, and
many times we aren't given the resources,
the confidence, even the self narrative
to know what we're capable of.
And one of the things that I'm
most proud about at Stanford is,
I think our program is designed to
help people understand who they are.
And again, get that confidence to really
dream big, and then upon graduation,
take the risks to make that happen.
So for anyone out in the audience who
does have things they believe that
they're capable of that
are bigger than themselves, and
for anyone out there who might
feel like but, I don't know,
it's time to take a step, and
we put on this application week for you.
If you don't believe in yourself and
begin there, no one else can or will.
But know that Will and myself and the rest
of our admissions team is looking forward
to learning more about you, to honoring
you, and no matter what happens,
it is a step for you to start
owning what you're capable of.
So, good luck and
I can't wait to learn more about you, and
you Will [LAUGH]
>> To bring this home,
I think Stanford is a place
where people see possibility.
They see possibility in themselves and
each other,
the way that we're going to be able to
tackle the world's biggest problems,
it's like yes, we can and
we're going to do this together.
And I think this is encapsulated
on the cornerstone, so
I don't have the inscription up in front
of me, so hopefully I get it right.
But it's dedicated to the things
that haven't happened yet, and
to the people who
are about to dream them up.
This is a place that's dedicated to you,
your dreams, your ideas,
the things that you want to do,
the things that haven't happened yet
that you might be the pioneer of.
Whether it is a new field or maybe
just the pioneer of tackling that new
little problem that you've
had that's been bugging you.
And now let's look at it
from a new direction,
this is a place where we want
you to dream big, lead boldly.
So if there's one thing that I could say
to all of you, it's dream big, y'all.
Thank you so much for joining us,
we hope you had a great time this week,
I know I did.
And we'll hope to see you soon, take care.
And from the Stanford Graduate School
of Business, we hope you
have a wonderful rest of the day, and
we hope to see your application soon.
[MUSIC]